こんにちははじめ社長です僕の神時ですネーム何とも言えない色なんですよ
クロッツ黒ですけどよく見ると実は茶色みたいな感じになってまして僕去年の夏
めちゃくちゃ金髪も白がにぐらいまで髪の毛染めすぎてめっちゃ痛んでるんです今だに
毛先
太良町ボラボラでもうこれじゃ僕は雷ガスト目のデーン止められるけど間抜の変化って
いうの見てみたいどんなかと思いながら大津屋さんは出てるとこういうものを見つけ
ました
こちら
me
[拍手]
ふぉろーるですちょっとロールでスプロールズエアーアレンジポピーのだけども
おおよそだと決闘つきませアーレン子ができるトロールのおもちゃですね
この女の子がニコニコ笑いながらトロールの髪の毛はポリてあげたりよろしてるわけ
ですよ
で z ロールじゃなくてよくね心人気なんか人気だったらいいですけどトロールの
ヘアアレンジ
はな目指す沿い
ちょっとする人がいるから商品化されてるんでしょうけどすごいビビったねドローンの
ヘアアレンジだってそうできるもんじゃないですかね
はいこの子がさボールですね裏がすごいガチガチすぎるとは
ぱおっぱ
はい出てきました
[音楽]
ちょっと怖いファイトいるとロールの女の子です本日は髪飾りパーツや串などでポピー
のヘアアレンジが楽しめるあなたはポピーっていうのね
僕はこういうのを恐れるグランドを取り星こういう感じでなんか神かなりとつけれる
らしいですね1回考え解いてあげましょうか
こういう髪型の女の子なのかな買ってもらってワックスとはでめっちゃ固められてる気
がするんですよねこのあ多分こういうカビよけの女のコスメ多分あの覚えてブロック c
で日付をすごいすごい
髪の毛めっちゃ傷んでますけど約日光等やすいてる
理由がん
まあはいとても素敵だと思いますいやー俺がこの子ピーちゃんに見いだしたのはそんな
ことじゃないヘアー年でも持つばしたいんですけどもこんな髪の毛の色
褐色すぎませんかなんだパピのも放送なのねもっとファレ日になりたいの
そうなのねってだけでこんな素敵な髪色の人なんてごく身近にいないんで今日はこんな
カラフルな土産の一つ買っ
てとある検証してみたいと思います日本人の踏み抜け手本的に黒だと思うんですけど
黒い髪の毛にハイブリッジを入れるともちろん金髪になると思いますですがこんな髪の
色の日本人はそうそういないこんな感じの人がハイブリッジするところで僕見たこと
ないんでこんなちょっとこの方に実験台になってもらってヘアー年次の一環として
ネジバナさんが人がハイブリッジをすると何
色になるのか吸収していきたいと思いますので今日はよろしくお願いします
体は早速やっていきましょうん
[音楽]
排除でできましたさっそくあなたを金髪にしていくばよ俺こんな神ゲーの色の人なんか
原宿とかで見たことあるんですけどもその人にさすがにハイブリッジしてくださいと
ea なのですごい今助かっておりますありがとうトロールさんては早速塗っていき
ます
[音楽]
ん
アースケーブルにはしやすいな思ったほど切り抜けそうですねこれは
[音楽]
ああって酔いすぎてがタッチ方すごいねあなた本当にライター大量はすごいですよ
ん
ちょっとまだ足りないんで付けいたします
よしいきます
[音楽]
ん
母校いろんなところに散らないとダメですからね
難しいところではありますが頑張ってまんべんなくつけていこうと思いますよ
[音楽]
ん
よしはいと良いで一緒に本尊付終わりましたつけたばかりでいろいろに食わないんです
けどもアン10分後どうなっているか見てみましょう
トロールじゃあもうちょい待っててね
おっ
うん
10分
[音楽]
ん
相手受けて30分が経過しました
え変わったかなやぱっと見わからんがちょっと落としみないと何とも言えないよを奏し
ています
ああああああ
ていた
カーン髪質が変わったけど実質カー
色変化ははから若干明るくなったんかな
何ともわからないですけど元マネ配備率しても意味が無かったですよ
俺を文もっと可愛いてシャビなっちまったんだ僕は勝ってくれそんなポピーをもっと
可愛くするためにとっちゃけのアイテムを3つかんだ
こちら9
黒染めええええやはりこの子の父として私は思うわけですそんなためだとジャイやはり
音なども誰もの苦労紙製とは一番可愛いんだと不安ねぼくいちゃんには黒柄になって
もらおうと思います黒染めでスクロールの女子がい
なんててくれアポ v 今プーさんが最高に来いくしてるからな
これでお前のスクールべくを打ち砕いた
アイクホビーお父さんに待たせねぇ
[音楽]
car
dea
me
あっはぁ